The Jesuits have influenced Hollywood
and the film industry since its very
inception. Check out this this document,
this essay uh this scholastic essay I
should say written by Henry Schnitzler.
He is uh a member of the department of
theater arts at UCLA
and this was actually um published by
John Hopkins and he talks about a Jesuit
priest called Anastasia Kercher who
invented the magic lantern which was the
first device to project images. Um
Kercher student another Jesuit Gaspar
Shot documented these advancements which
later paved the way for motion pictures
which is what our whole movie industry
is based on. Another Jesuit Cloud
Francis Miller Chalet discovered that
the human eye perceives light color
rather than objects in motion which was
a foundational principle of film making.
But why would the Jesuits, a religious
order, invest so much in visual
storytelling? According to Encyclopedia
Britannica, Jesuit theater was
specifically designed, not surprising,
to counter the Protestant Reformation.
And and we see this as well in in this
academic article that Henry Schnitzler
wrote for the John Hopkins University
Press. He writes about the educational
system the Jesuits created. How they had
become the school masters of Europe.
Their education was to serve as a
fighting force in the struggle against
the new faith, meaning the Protestant
Reformation. Jesuit's performance was to
be an irresistible appeal to the senses
and emotions rather than to the
intellect and reason. A spectator was to
be virtually hypnotized by a concerted
attack of all known theatrical devices
until he surrendered his entire being to
the drama's spiritual message. They
shrewly disguised it under a colorful
cloak of splendid entertainment. There
was not a single theatrical genre that
could not at some time or place be seen
in the Jesuit theater. E even if those
genres were not even closely religious,
these genres were admitted to the Jesuit
schools only as long as they could be
made to serve the orders. Listen to this
neverchanging aim. The Jesuits saw the
theater as a powerful weapon for the
implementation of counterreformatory
propaganda. So it created the Jesuit
school theater. It was in every way a
propaganda theater used for
propagandistic ends. These were
naturally more conspicuous during the
first decades of the order's existence
when new ground had to be won chiefly by
reaching huge audiences and impressing
them with the spiritual message of Roman
Catholicism.
So, so let's fast forward to today. The
entertainment industry operates in
really much the same way. It's appealing
to the emotions and senses using
Hollywood as a vehicle to relay a
message and change society. Um, so I I
always like to think of it as like I've
got them sitting there. Whip a little
message at them. Whip a little moral at
them. Whip a little of what my view of
the world is cuz that's what every good
filmmaker does. But are the Jesuits
still involved in Hollywood now?
Absolutely. This clip from Jesuits in
America, a documentary, explains more.
link in the description to get yourself
a copy of this documentary.
Some believe that Hollywood movies are
really a modern version of what was
known as Jesuit theater in centuries
past,
where the order communicated ideas
through dramatic plays.
The book Jesuit Hollywood by Shaun
Wilcock documents how Jesuits use
theater as part of the
counterreformation to refute the
anti-apist dramas inspired by Martin
Luther.
Wilcock writes that the Jesuits saw the
theater as having a very great purpose
in their schemes to promote Jesuit
religious propaganda to the masses.
[Music]
Far from being a minor instrument for
teaching, the Jesuits incorporated the
use of dramas, dance, and opera in their
schools and missions around the world.
In the 20th century, they were even
responsible for creating the official
production code for making movies in
Hollywood.
Also called the Hayes Code after
Congressman William Hayes. It was
originally intended to prevent immoral
practices from being communicated on
film. The code was developed by Catholic
publisher Martin Quigley along with a
Jesuit priest named the Reverend Daniel
Lord.
The code was upheld for some 20 years by
a Jesuit educated Catholic named Joseph
Breen who became the central figure
associated with the moral boundaries
imposed on the film industry.
At one point, Breen was even said to
have more influence over world opinion
than Hitler, Mussolini or Stalin because
of the tremendous power he had over the
content of Hollywood movies.
And the way in which they captured the
mind
was through Jesuit theater. Now this is
where you come in. Hollywood. There was
a Jesuit and his name was Kenor.
Now in German Kino is a biocope is a
theater.
And he invented an instrument which
through flashing lights could cast
images on a screen. Interesting. And
that became the movie. Wow. Production.
So yes. So the Jesuits became not only
the school masters, they also became the
masters of the theater. Wow. And they
were the first master class. Yes. And
where they couldn't infiltrate directly,
they used the theater. Now there's a
high probability that Shakespeare
might not even have been a literal
person, but was a pseudonym for someone
in the high esoteric circles like Sir
Francis Bacon.
for example, and he was a rosacrruian,
so he would have a high esoteric
knowledge and would probably be able to
write something like Mc Beth or or one
of them. Mhm. And once you divert the
mind into this esoteric fairy tale
world, then you can implant anything
else. Now, that's your line. So, I'm
going to go there. you're you're
speaking my language. But that is one
thing that I think really is tying all
of these different I mean you think of
all the different production companies
all the different people involved all
the different span I mean there's
there's armies of people how are you
getting all their messages similar army
is a very good name now the Jesuits are
also a military organization I was
thinking about that Napoleon called the
Jesuits an army instead of a religious
organization well Napoleon was a high
Jes
was a high mason because he put all of
his his family into high uh secret
society positions. But that being as it
as it may, they then created all the
great schools like Georgetown University
or Foram University or many of them are
not directly linked to them but actually
through the committees controlled by
them. So let's say that a large
proportion of the of the world of
education today is based on the
philosophy of the Jesuits. Mhm. And they
are the ones that train the presidents
whether that be uh whoever Donald Trump.
Yeah. There's there's enough evidence
out there that they have all been parts
and bits. They've all been part of it.
We don't have to go into all of them but
uh yes they all somehow associated and
trained in this and they are highmasons.
Mhm. Is it the same Jesuits and Masons
are the same? No. Okay. Masons are an
organization that at its basis should
actually be Protestant.
But this is the beauty of the deception.
You create an organization then you ban
it. Right? So Rome make it intriguing.
Rome officially banned the Masonic order
and said it was of the devil. All Masons
are from the devil while every single
cardinal in the Vatican was a Mason.
So that's pretty hypocritical. That's
pretty hypocritical. They're true
though. That's true. So that is how you
draw them in. As long as you're at the
top controlling the situation and
controlling the teachings, then you have
drawn in the Protestant world and you
are actually controlling it without them
knowing it. So I think from what I
remember from watching your total
onslaught series is that the Roman
Catholic Church technically is at the
helm of all these secret societies. Yes.
How how so? How come? Well, they have
these two two orders. the one that that
still remain to this day and that is the
Jesuit order which has a general which
is generally called the black pope
and uh he has absolute authority and do
we know who this black pope is? Yeah,
it's public knowledge currently. Yeah.
Yes. And they've they change regularly
as time goes on but they basically their
power is absolute. And then you have the
um Knights of Malta. The Knights of
Malta are also military order. Both of
them are military orders. Now if you if
you take the Knights of Malta, they have
the Maltese cross, but they're subject
to the Jesuits.
So there were actually physical wars in
order to control this issue. So
eventually the knights of Malta became
subject to the Jesuits and they they
work in unity. And then you have many
suborders within the the Opus Day and
all of these that also swear allegiance
to the papacy or the Knights of Columbus
which are Catholic organization
uh promising to bring Catholic ideas
into politics etc etc and you belong to
one or the other. And if you look at the
history of presidential candidates, they
will either come from a opus background
or a Georgetown background or a Ford ham
background or any one of those.
So the Knights of Malta are a huge
organization
and they have they call themselves the
hospitalers of St. John's and they have
the Maltes cross as their symbol. Now if
you take the kings of Europe, they all
wear malties crosses. They're they're
nothing other than vassels to the pop.
Mhm. And uh they control vast
organizations and vast financial
organizations. And probably most of the
great uh theaters and sports clubs, they
all are owned and controlled. I wouldn't
say all, but the majority controlled by
Knights of Malta. that brings the
philosophy
into the world. If you like this video,
like, subscribe, and hit the
notification bell so you know when we
launch new videos. And drop a comment
below, and we'll try to get back to you
if we can. What?
Say that again. Oh, no. I don't know
what to say.
[Music]